together
all right beautiful song
beautiful song
hey
[Laughter]
you want some gum yes
yes Finnegan I would love some gum
this is great stuff
fry was it spry spry gum with Xylitol
Finnegan that is a delight
where can I get this oh boy anywhere
really CVS Acme HEB viral drugs
Associated food stores
Earth Fare yeah what's up have you seen
my propeller cap because I can't find
anywhere it was probably in the costume
let's check there well yeah I already
checked it's not there Martin's I don't
get go find it
mayor Natural Grocers Riley
right what about what about uh online oh
for sure uh iherb Amazon Lucky Vitamin
uh vitacos oh yeah I've heard of this
it's got the the xylitol is good for
your the bacteria in your mouth like you
can use it between brushing it's
actually good for your teeth unlike
normal gum which is only going to rot
your teeth and you're my son of a
[Music]
all right
foreign
for the best in Dental defense products
including gum mouthwash toothpaste go to
xclear.com that's spelled xlear.com like
clear.com Amazon or your local pharmacy
and to see the the published data on the
benefits
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
don't tweet anything anti-semitic don't
tweet anything anti-semitic uh just did
dang it hey tweet team I said no
anti-Semitism they just they always get
it wrong
are we talking about yay today I keep
wanting to say ye but we'll be talking
about Kanye West being sued uh for uh
you know saying what uh his uh uh
medically accurate regarding George
Floyd and uh hey remember when they said
would stop with Alex Jones well here we
are
you're next and Joy Reid look this is my
question for you this is a genuine
question I've sort of changed a little
bit on this I used to always say don't
attribute to malice what you can
attribute to ignorance and in your
day-to-day life I absolutely believe
that but people in the media
specifically like Joy Reed for example
not like Joy read specifically Joy read
and you get out of the habit of saying
like um
or um
Joy read everything that she has said
about Florida and the scientists every
single portion of her statement a one
paragraph statement
is wrong I can't believe that she's
ignorant I think it's a lie do you think
that what you're seeing from the left
now do you think it's ignorance do you
think it's a difference of opinion or do
you think they're in so deep they're
just going to lie about it anyway I'm
really curious to see your answers here
because I've evolved on that I used to
try and give them the benefit of the
doubt now no benefit
like a right to work state okay we'll be
talking about that and a new super covet
coming your way oh Jeremy how are you
I'm doing well how are you I'm good I'm
doing fine oh this is this is the merch
up I forgot the Halloween shirts I mean
it may not know it's a little late for
buying it for Halloween but buy it
because it's fun all year you can use it
for next time that's exactly right or
you can use it to scare people all year
wrong there's there's gonna be another
Halloween all year round I meant to say
long or round but I said oh you're wrong
by the way I got something wrong
yesterday I don't know if I need to be
admonished now or later well it's not
exactly breaking news I said that's fair
I I said
Yorkies instead of corgis oh those are
totally different pooches and I screwed
that one corgis were used largely to
warm the foot of the royal bed yes
Yorkies are the uh they were made for
dog fighting and they're easier to drown
in a cappuccino cappuccino machine
really little known facts when they lose
on Bill Gates and Jeff Bezos hosting dog
fighting if they were Michael Vick I
highly recommend it one of the best
comedians working today and one of the
best comedians working today I don't
want to say the best for anyone because
then they'll all get mad and jealous and
I'll get letters but the fastest man on
his feet I'm on tour with him we only
have shows left at two two dates right
only tickets left for two shows
Nashville November 12th at the Ryman
Auditorium we added a second show so
that's like 2500 seats times two you
guys sold out the first one like that
demanded a second one you can get your
tickets at letterscutter.com tour
Dave Landau how are you Ahoy good how
about you sir oh my goodness I can't
even be seen but what happened I don't
know it must be why is he so dark it's
because I'm bezeled out maybe Darkwing
Dave Dark Wing day let's get dangerous
yeah suck gas evil door oh we're just
gonna turn me off is that what happened
I think he just shut me off they just
did you just turn him off yep he's still
dark I'm sorry so what happens is the
static in the studio will reset the
camera so we gotta reset it this is well
this is a good time as any before we get
to the stories that actually matter Dave
you're going to be a Kansas City improv
all weekend I am I'm going to be the
Kansas City improv all weekend but
there's an overlay where they can see
you I appreciate that yes come out to
the comedy club uh and then yes of
course uh and thank you for the
compliment Steve and I feel the same
about you you can come see us out on the
road in uh Jersey and uh jersey sold out
is it yeah there's only Baltimore and
the second show at Nashville oh that's
right we only have Nashville number two
and I think yeah the those are moving
quick I'm excited to do that the Grand
old Opry we'll see what it's like it's
now the Ryman but it's the original
Grand old Opry I'm really excited about
that actually
yeah in the very very back control room
be sure to revoke Gerald's tickets if he
comes near the stage yeah I will hurt
him if he comes near the venue I know
yeah we've told him he's not allowed
it's weird you guys have a restraining
order on me at these venues yep yeah we
don't think it you didn't know I filed
it under domestic abuse and by the way
we also happen to have a civil union
that you signed while you were drunk yes
oh Lord and I want to wish a happy
birthday to Snoop Dogg yeah I'm bezeld
out a little bit d-o-g you don't honor
rappers while they're alive
but he if you count uh the products he
endorses he died a long time ago that's
true
Corona yeah rolling down the streets
this is not like iced tea selling
whatever it is reverse mortgages
boom done I used to jack cars now I
Shield him and Shaq doing this listen to
me don't beat your wife if you have
joint pain
get your icy hot and then rub some
Tussin is your elbow the size of an
elephant hip Icy Hot would you run from
the police and now your feet all sweaty
and you might want to think about wool
socks if it's moisture Wicked yes it
Wicks moisture grip nine
socks Martha Stewart was the pillowcase
that they gave me
all right so we have so much to get to
here today and you know what look it's a
Thursday it's a slow news day but this
all affects you remember everyone
thought it would stop with Alex Jones
didn't Kanye West right now with George
Floyd the family and something people
don't do you know this at Kanye West did
you know that Kanye West paid for the
tuition of George Floyd's daughter
did you know that no no good deed goes
unpunished I guess true yes uh so here's
before we get to that I don't know if
you know this it's very unpopular
for us to be uh to be white is it it's
not a good thing right now it's not it's
not in it's not in Vogue I'm not black
If Only Could you know we were born for
the we were born the wrong time well I'm
not should have been like the early 18th
century yep the Kings yeah we'd be
totally cool yep could be standard
height yeah I know maybe a giant hey
Gerald would be Goliath well he would
already be dead yes they picked me and
be like yes we must kill the tall one
nobody his height lived past 22 back
then right yeah you're basically just
being synthetically kept alive at this
point it's all artificial I'd be what
they called slightly above average yes
in in 1854 wait you want me to box under
Queensbury rules Mr Landau he's enormous
all right I'll butter your biscuits yes
yes I'll take this stance that allows me
no facial protection but guarantees a
Breaking of my wrist let's go
all right so here it is unpopular to be
white here's a guy this is this is not
fully new but I think that it deserves
more attention than it's gotten
you'll see why uh he's sitting in his
backyard uh and at first I thought
Mozambique turns out it's not uh saying
that uh you know you if you're white
like this is just this is the kind of
racism that really is just it's just
plain it's not Reverse Racism it's just
racism racism
the nature of a white person is evil you
cannot run away from that fact and when
it comes to us as Eternal people oh that
guy better be in Zambia devilish not in
Poughkeepsie we are imitating the ways
and the culture of these Devils we want
to be like these Devils we want to talk
like these Devils we want to walk like
these Devils we want to have the money
that these Devils have
okay Poor Man's Coolio
I gotta be honest I think it's the other
way around
this is just that that's a guy in
Houston I thought yeah he's in Houston
Texas dressed that way yeah
calling us white devil in Quincy
wearing his mom's old sex curtain yeah
oh it's all leopard the white devil oh
okay how do you usually dress yeah
that's not I don't think that's that's
erroneous it's not it's not erroneous
I'm willing to bet that your benefit hey
aren't you Taping that aren't you
filming that on this uh modern
technology a camera phone yeah you just
didn't go into Brooks Brothers yes
you're like you can't get wider man yeah
he's a model for J crew yeah no more EPS
son I will take your money but I will
use it to subvert the white Devil's
money against him it's Jiu Jitsu against
the white devil hey imagine you just
said just look that's just racism racism
and I'm not saying all black people
believe that but that is everything that
is wrong with Society it's phony it's
fraudulent just like a lot of hip-hop
artists it's just that doesn't have
anything to do with your culture sounds
like you got a lot of land that you're
complaining from that probably cost him
money can we play let me I want to see
something again I think I might have
missed something actually as I saw this
earlier let me see it the nature of a
white person is evil
oh yeah no that's a Hot Topic friend
bracelet change
it's a goth girls like beaded yeah
necklace he's got the love bead on there
so be careful he's got Super Mario
underwear all right well message not
taken
ah well I am a little devilish yes yes
we are he's not completely wrong no so
here's another example uh of and this
just happened this happened 16 years ago
I believe but you know there's this myth
going around and I think it's important
this will tie into what we talk about
with with Kanye and joy read because
this really is sort of an episode about
the dishonesty of media and how it's
gone completely unchecked for a very
long time and I get that a lot of you
you watching right now you might say hey
the Democratic party left me or I miss
the time of Walter Cronkite and Dan
Rather back when journalists there never
was journalism in this country just so
you know everyone has always had a bias
they just used to lie to you about it so
uh case in point here the media's always
been incompetent or uh blatantly
dishonest in this case completely
incompetent to a level that is hilarious
we have irrefutable absolute proof
foreign
so if you don't remember this
16 years ago today let me set up this
clip the BBC uh here's the thing they
interviewed a taxi driver okay but they
they actually sold him to the public as
a tech expert and the taxi driver found
this out live on air now that you
understand Marley's debt to begin with
watch it unfold in real time the most
respected name in English news
well guy CUNY is the editor of the
technology website a news Wireless hello
good morning to you good morning were
you surprised by This Server dick today
I'm very surprised to see this verdict
to come on me because
they told me something else and I'm
coming you got an interview there so
it's a big surprise anyway a big
surprise yes yes
um with regards to uh the cost that's in
involved
um do you think now more people will be
downloading online actually if you can
go everywhere you're gonna you're gonna
see a lot of people downloading to the
internet and your website everything
they want but I think it's it's much
better for uh to import people what they
want trying to get on the easy way and
so fast everything they're looking for
[Laughter]
technological expert he's like oh [ __ ]
Are we going to bring up how I was
robbed yes I I'm just here to take
someone to the next building I was here
to tell you about how I had Saudi
passengers who had a pressure cooker
with Nails in it yes
so you can just interview anybody and
say there's someone yes no they didn't
know I guarantee they screwed up some
interns screwed up somewhere like walked
him in like this is no no he did a very
good job about the internet this is the
one with email yes correct yes yes yes
uh very happy to be here uh talking
about Netscape Navigator sometimes I've
I Ask Jeeves yeah
meanwhile this is a guy waiting in the
office just getting yelled at I don't
have a taxi why do you keep asking me to
drive you Tim Cook being escorted by
security yeah they're just like could
you just be a little more patient please
sir we'll get to you but he's on TV now
here's the point if nothing else just
don't when people blame you for not
trusting institutions we get blamed all
the time and oh you don't trust the
institutions you don't trust the
electoral process oh you don't trust the
media oh you don't trust your elected
representatives
whose fault is it this has been going on
look this happened to me one time when I
was on Fox News uh and they told me that
I was going to be I think I was going to
be talking about something that was
domestic and then they asked me about
the North Korean conflict I was like uh
whatever
[Applause]
I just said like our expert dropped out
can you show up I'm like yeah but I'm
not an expert though and then I realized
I was just as much of an expert that guy
honestly is passable as a tech expert I
can't tell the difference no I would
have no I mean he was right yeah
his assessment was spot on and just
going yes people will be downloading
more stuff and using the internet more
they will yep I don't think you really
download websites but but yeah I mean
just naming internet where it's like uh
website yes you can download sometimes
the h o the the TTS I include the PE yes
um the porn is free Mouse yeah double
click
a Yellow Cab yeah
it's a it's a good day yeah and he's
like fascinating thank you very much we
have to have you back please let's back
and put them in our guest Rolodex and
bringing you all the News That's fit to
print if an Apple logo right behind me
[Laughter]
should have brought up the kid from
blank check oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
that's a real con man uh by the way in
other news uh speaking of British the
Prime Minister Liz truss after 40
something days resigned
um
okay so it's a live show Monday through
Thursday 10 a.m Eastern if you're on
YouTube I would love for you to switch
over to rumble or of course mug Club
will be taking its chat Thursday yeah 10
a.m Eastern Monday through Thursday
because notifications don't work that's
why we have to hit like share comment
all of that for the algorithm otherwise
just head on over Rumble and Mud Club I
would love to not have to worry about
YouTube anymore oh please all right
speaking of things you're not allowed to
discuss
superbugs
oh so you know how you uh generally
speaking the best way to learn from
learn for the future is to learn from
your past mistakes and correct them yes
yes and everyone here knows about the
you know covet in the lab yeah okay good
yeah yeah maybe possibly yeah just based
on the way the show is going I wasn't
sure if we were on the same page yep
okay so
the researchers at Boston University
seamless did the opposite of that and
they developed a new strain of covid in
a lab why would researchers
intentionally do this
you know
um there's something about Omicron that
it was less virulent but more
transmissible we all knew this by this
point and we have multiple studies that
show it's less virulent so they wanted
to see
red Mr Freeze before you hit that made
it less virulent by sticking it's not a
gizmos
of covid-19 Omicron onto the ancestral
strain and then they found that whatever
the ancestral strain had over here
beyond the spike protein that was what
was leading to virulence because this is
a very deadly strain and it's very
transmissible both it has all the worst
things going for it uh in terms of
causing disease so I have to say I'm a
little bit worried
um that this is created and I think
Point proven let's destroy this now well
are they just method acting as the mayor
from every natural disaster film ever
yeah yes
we worried that we've created this holy
crap we need to destroy it now yeah
let's do it again I think we'll get it
right next time yeah you know hey they
can't all be gems let's see what this
new extra deadly strain does yeah yeah
hey you guys want to cure it no I got an
idea let's make a worse version of it
yes oh yeah I like that let's make more
of it yeah remember how the first one of
these that was more deadly spread around
the entire Globe like really from a wet
Market let's let's make it spread faster
not from a lab from a wet Market from a
wet Market from a wet laboratory Market
where they were slaughtering animals
without using proper hygiene yeah
speaking of which I'm gonna go get some
bat sandwiches anybody up for lunch yeah
well I I want grilled I don't like to
eat fried food in the day it makes me
sluggish no yeah it does
it's fine braised is fine
black broiled that's what I was looking
for make mine broiled yeah I want it
flavorless and great so here's the thing
the story was run by Daily Mail not to
be clear they claimed the new strain has
an 80 kill rate right but in a lab
that's different from what happens in
the general population now okay
the original strain of covet had a 100
kill rate on the mice just to be clear
so it's not necessarily more deadly but
you heard her say that it could be
pretty deadly more deadly than Omicron
more virulent but we don't have a ton of
information on this here's the deal okay
and you can comment below I'm very
curious to hear where you line up
I'm not afraid to stick my neck out on
these and say that I think creating new
deadly viruses in a laboratory is as a
is generally bad
yeah
I'm anti that
yeah so it doesn't really seem though
like these people when you think about
it what we've been through the last two
years it just doesn't seem like they've
been even trying to learn their lesson I
think you've just been canceled genetic
power is is the greatest force uh on the
planet and you wield it around like a
kid who just has found his dad's gun
um so your scientists were so
preoccupied with the question on if they
could right they never never stopped to
ask if they should
if evolutionary history has taught us
anything it's well you know
life will not be contained it's uh it's
that's it simply
life uh
finds a way
okay thank you Dr Michael I don't even
know why we have a couch in the studio I
mean yeah it's weird it was just brought
in today yeah I didn't see him come in
no I didn't see him either we really
should have you know like a lock that'd
be helpful Sorry by the way we also
found that this disease in the lab uh
was created by uh Dr super uh an even
more lethal version of Dr fauci so it
seems like it's following a trend of
foreign
[Laughter]
I hear that guy kills like 63 beagles a
minute oh no no try 75 days actually no
the new one though the new super once
it's a thousand but it's it's a
veritable Posh Fitz
[Laughter]
it's warpaw
oh yeah just we could easily do a seven
plus one oh easy on dog concentration
camps I think I'm gonna get that
tattooed on my back [ __ ] out they they
huddle and they release the zycon Beagle
all right
hit the like button if you're okay with
how dark that got is so
oh please hit the like I just am amazed
that like this is again the media you
think they're experts you think that uh
people who work in Laboratories the
scientists you think they're experts
trust the science don't mistrust your
institutions like media this is a very
broad umbrella media science you see
what they do why do we act as though
they are Beyond making mistakes like the
rest of us when they're financially
incentivized to do so you know you've
bitched about click bait we all
understand that clickbait where people
will if you don't know what that is it's
where people put in a title that's not
very accurate you click it and now
they've had your click they've generated
an end dollar that's completely
inaccurate well what do you think
happens when you encourage more and more
faster more so that you get another
grant that you get the public attention
only with science it's click bait
science and all the beagles die
save the beagles yeah true that's true
yeah Air Bud 19. yep actually you know
what killed the beagles never mind yeah
Weird Science if it keeps us from having
another Air Bud I'm fine
what just inject him with air
you don't want to have a kicker that's a
dog no because the rulebook doesn't say
anything about dogs what about a golden
Receiver yes
come on I like that one can I have it
please airpod 24.
he's a Pfizer intern he's just shaking
and gray they've never replaced Air Bud
he can't catch anything
except the super virus now uh Kanye or
Yeezy or yay as he likes to be called
is it Diddy
are we down to Diddy it was Puff Daddy
then it was Daddy then it was P Diddy
are we down to Diddy it became ditty and
then I I think it became didio did it no
I am oh
but I did think it became something else
I could be wrong though stop changing
your names guys Sean Combs yes
that's a terrible name in Monster's Ball
he was Sean Combs yes and that was the
only time yes yes also uh yeah I don't
think there's anything that destroys
your street cred more than doing
proactive commercials with Vanessa
Williams oh yeah that destroys
everything you're saying he's like your
boy did he told you proactive you've got
zip uh
50 Cent was shot in the face nine times
and I was like I got a blackhead
[ __ ] man you know that's why
Nelly wore that Band-Aid right I
guarantee you it was a zit that he
couldn't cover up and he's like I'm
gonna make this my thing I always wear a
Band-Aid it'd be smart pockmark you
don't want people to see that right you
gotta look tough because it's all in
your head
yeah nothing looks tougher than a
Band-Aid
commercials
on it Flintstones yeah it's a remix I am
stuck on Band-Aids because germs don't
stick on me ha
fine that's what it's going hot it's
like a little blowhole
his next one is yeah
[Laughter]
like a really really big one yeah that's
when you had a sebaceous cyst ah I also
understand why he wore that gear I could
never understand the m m uh wearing the
do-rag with the hat on top well you know
it's it's good in arid regions yeah I
guess I don't know sure like that guy in
Houston who wanted us to think that he
was from the Congo I hope he got eight
Alive by mosquitoes yes everywhere in
Houston all right well don't joke about
that they have malaria in Houston so and
cheetahs so Kanye Yeezy yay okay he's
being sued for 250 million dollars okay
he's also been issued a cease and desist
letter now here's why from the family of
George Floyd this is why he is being
sued and this is important it does
affect you it's easy to say oh this
person's a celebrity it's easy to say oh
he put out some anti-semitic tweets or
oh he's bipolar whatever issue it is
that you have with Kanye West but when
you understand why he's actually being
hit with this fine why he actually may
might face legal ramifications and what
actually happened with Alex Jones I
recommend you go and watch our episode
with him
it is having right now the effect that
they wanted it to have and we'll show
you their exact words but these are the
statements that got Yeezy in hot water
the family of George Floyd is preparing
to file a 250 million dollar lawsuit
against Kanye West
uh it comes after the rapper who now
legally goes by the name yay said in a
podcast that Floyd died from a fentanyl
overdose and not from Suffocation after
having a police officer's knee on his
neck for more than nine minutes okay so
that's them telling I think we have a
clip from what yay I keep wanting to say
ye actually said here you go watch the
George Floyd documentary that Candace
Owens Put up one of the things that his
two roommates said was why they yelling
they want a tall guy like me they want a
tall guy like me hit him with the
Fentanyl
if you look the the guy's knee wasn't
even on his neck like that when he said
mama mama is his girlfriend they said he
screamed for his mama mama was his
girlfriend it's in the documentary the
free George Floyd Zone that they made
the murder rate is up 50 since George
Floyd it's Mayhem it's it's Mad Max okay
so uh the suit claims that his comments
are detrimental quote too George Floyd's
daughter and uh as the sole beneficiary
of his estate that's why they're
claiming these damages this is after
again all references available at
letterscore.com Yeezy Kanye paid 2
million dollars
towards George Floyd's George Floyd's
family for his daughter's tuition
so again this does matter this you may
not like what he said you may not like
how he said it but this
Thai spirit is even though he disagrees
with the media narrative
two million dollars to the daughter at
that point because his heart went out to
her don't when do we get to the point
where we start judging people based on
their actions more than the words we
can't because we have to judge him on
skin color we have to judge them on
gender we have to judge them on
political affiliation we have to judge
them based on not only their own gender
but where they line up on the other
countless slash 52 slash it just changed
to 74 genders two million dollars to the
family and by the way everything that he
just said
is accurate yeah but everybody's going
to try and silence him and not I you
know we didn't even know you and I both
didn't know that he had contributed any
money to the fact I'd forgotten it yeah
and so it was money towards the family
and towards her education if she spends
two million dollars on a college
education I'm not exactly sure where
she's going right but no he's he's
supporting people when they're in need
and then they're turning around and
suing him for 250 million dollars I
don't understand where the damages come
from I don't know okay so they're saying
and they're trying to be very opaque
about it they're trying to say that it's
causing damages because this was settled
in court he wasn't killed by the drugs
it was shaven and it settled and
something interesting is that if Kanye
goes in it goes into the paint here yeah
guess what uh that might actually Force
an acquittal for Chavin if he now goes
through a lawsuit and can prove that no
wait a second there were other reasons
that contributed to his death there are
a lot of Dynamics at play this is to
silence someone with a platform you have
a big enough platform they will try and
silence you it's not about the kind of
platform that you have right now it's do
you a either wants to be able to have a
platform any platform and B do you
understand that it's necessary for
people on your side to have platforms
now let's go through George Floyd's
autopsy report at the time of death and
we've done this a lot we we went through
this topic not Ad nauseam as it was
taking place but okay there are no
life-threatening injuries that were
identified okay there was no physical
trauma to the neck he had covid he had
hypertensive heart disease he had
artheos
I can never say it you know the Hard
video school erotic heart disease yeah
artheliosclerosis I can never say it can
you say it don't make me look can you
say serious no that's not what it is I
mean that's arterial sclerotic heart
disease I'm trying to say the word that
people know in their head I don't know I
can't say arthritic
why are you here
and by the way the most arterio as
credit R Kelly heart disease yes all
right Archie Bunker so uh the meth
levels in a system were 19 nanograms per
milliliter okay and there were various
forms of fentanyl uh it was a cornucopia
fentanyl uh totaling around 16.6
nanograms wow again all the references
are available at creditor.com hit the
like button if you want to help the
algorithm here because a lot of people
still don't know this information the
lethal amount of fentanyl uh
particularly in combination with other
drugs so they have the threshold right
lethal and Fentanyl and then of course
that threshold changes if it's in
combination with other drugs you ever
taken medication at home and says do not
combine with other medications do not
combine with alcohol it's very common we
all know it they didn't talk about this
in the media so the lethal dose I think
it's the mean dose of lethality for
fentanyl in combination with other drugs
is only seven nanograms
per milliliter oh again he was at 16.6
and 19 anagrams of Meth
which we know by the way meth of course
is one of the worst drugs to combine
with any of the drugs by itself it's a
wonderful solo artist I highly recommend
it yes no only if you don't want to have
teeth yeah or you don't want to sleep
for nine days and you want just don't
don't take it unless you want your
apartment to be pristine and live
forever yes yes I was really interested
in this I thought once the tempers kind
of flared down a little bit on this we
could go back and review the actual
evidence of this case right and see like
the information like this if you look at
this in a vacuum and you don't have the
social outcry that was going on during
this trial and during that time you're
like wow this guy left to his own
devices in that car probably dies within
hours right at the very least and even
the corner we'll talk about in a minute
the corner even said like yeah if you
find him at his home absent any other
trauma you're like that's one hell of a
drug overdose well you know what let's
run guys I know we have that clip from
our show we'll run that last but here
don't take my word for it here's a video
presented during the shavan trial of
George Floyd in other words to hear
George Floyd say it and again this is a
tragedy of course you don't you never
want to see someone someone diet whether
they're in custody or at their house
it's a life lost but he said I took too
much drugs
[Music]
did you hear that yes I did did it
appear that Mr Floyd said I ate too many
drugs yes it did
now does that mean it's spelled too
right does that mean that it's the only
relevant no but it is relevant very
relevant and we've gone from
Alex Jones right well don't say that the
parents are crisis actors and harass
them which never actually he never told
people to harass him he did say that he
thought it was a hoax at one point that
was his opinion but people would say
that's an extreme exact if if he just
didn't do that he wouldn't be sued and
he wouldn't have lost well hold on a
second regardless of where you line up
Kanye repeated what George Floyd himself
said and the autopsy report reveals
that's worthy of a lawsuit
do do you start do you start seeing the
picture here
and just in case you've forgotten
remember the prosecute from The Alex
Jones trial said that this was not only
to hurt Alex Jones but to remove his
platform and to act as a deterrent to
anyone else speaking out that was the
goal of it
I ask that with your verdict you not
only
take Alex Jones platform that he talks
about a way I ask that you make certain
you can't rebuild the platform that's
what matters
take him out of this discourse of this
misinformation of this peddling of lies
and make sure he can't do it again
that is punishment
that is deterrence so I ask of you to
take the bullhorn away from Alex Jones
and take the first steps towards taking
that bullhorn away from all the others
who have it or all the others who might
want it all the others who believe they
can profit off of fear and
misinformation
make them understand that they too will
sit their ass in that chair right there
and have to actually respond
in a court of law for what they do if
they choose to do the same thing that
Alex Jones did
a couple of things they weren't able to
prove that Alex Jones profited off it
they just meant that his show was
profitable and at some point he
mentioned Sandy Hook out of the years
and three hours a day of footage they
could only find 25 minutes and honestly
it wasn't nearly as damning as you would
think but let me ask you this it's about
the profit right that was the argument
it's because what Alex Jones said was so
crazy all right what Kanye has said now
is is not that crazy whether you
disagree or not it's certainly certainly
factual when he said there were drugs in
his system that George Floyd said he had
consumed uh too high of a dose of drugs
when the autopsy report reveals that the
blood levels are higher than the lethal
dose required okay let's ask another
question how is Kanye profiting off of
it
how is Kanye profiting off of it you
could maybe argue if he has a single
called George Floyd didn't die
[Laughter]
right but how is he prop it's not about
the fact that Alex Jones is profiting
off it which they didn't prove it's not
about the fact that what he said was so
radical it is as he said removing the
bullhorn from anyone else hey
who's next because I don't believe
personally that George Floyd died
because of the niana's neck I think it
was bad practice from the police I think
they were trained improperly because
that was a practice that was taught to
the police department but I will say
that that 100 okay irrefutably just a
knee on the neck from 165 pound man uh
would not kill someone in that amount of
time why
well I don't know is this worthy of a
lawsuit I did it
well now absolutely people watching I'm
not saying that it's Pleasanton I'm
asking would this kill someone somebody
can do just fine in this position it's
uncomfortable but it's not going to kill
them right now you don't know what I I
will actually go further than that my uh
you know I do grappling uh and my father
who's a one minute a brown belt it's far
more uncomfortable for me to be under
side control for him I would not be able
to maintain that for nine minutes and by
the way I have been talking this whole
time and in case people wonder I talk
really fast and uh I have a you know I
have a recognition that's a chest
condition where my bone grows into my
heart I have to get surgery in July the
point is sounds like l or Alf the point
is that this is probably more difficult
than it is for a lot of you out there
watching uh but I also don't have four
times the lethal dose of fentanyl in my
system and again I'm already laying down
because this is more comfortable
okay I didn't hear seek I couldn't hear
you back then I didn't realize you said
I sounded like else well you did oh I
guess I shouldn't have taken that Spain
ball place with fentanyl
I should stay away from meth and stick
with consuming cats
[Laughter]
hanging out with the dad on his show we
just love the track oh yeah he'd be a
fan oh yeah exactly be like yes let's do
those drugs the guy I want to replace
one of the words that he said he's like
I want to use and I'm going to say
exactly what he said I want them to have
to sit their ass in that chair and
answer for free speech yep that's
exactly what he wants he wants to put
free speech on trial by the way Alex
Jones wasn't the first person to talk
about that Alex Jones wasn't calling for
people to go after them Kanye certainly
is not the first person to say that
George Floyd would have died from those
drugs and that no the knee wasn't on the
neck like that he's certainly not the
first individual the only reason I know
that is because we watched the trial
that was the defense right that was what
evidence was presented to prove how in
the world can you go after somebody for
merely in expressing expressing an
opinion that's already out there and it
has been that's by design it came that's
by Design it's not by accident well a
billion dollars in advertisement is a
lot for that particular topic right yeah
I mean that's really I don't I don't
understand well I don't understand how
people think that this is a great way to
go like he's definitely going after Free
Speech Alex Jones as much as you may
hate what he said had a right to say it
and Kanye certainly has a right to say
it
he absolutely has a right to say it and
everything that he has said is factually
correct you may not like the tone of it
keep in mind this is a guy who gave two
million dollars to the daughter of
George foot what have you virtue
signaling white Knights on Tick Tock
done
actions should matter remember we judge
people by their actions they're like
what we virtue signaled yes we did we
said that Kanye is bad yes what are you
going to do to solve the problem well
I'm gonna talk about it we're actually
going to hold a meeting there right next
to the cup of foods I couldn't burn his
physical album so I just smashed my
phone yes uh but no are you actually
going to raise money and do any what no
we I like I said we've talked about it
so it's good right yes I'll get another
one from Apple made by a young young
young boy yes exactly
of Oriental origin by the way I ignore
that one silver lining this is the first
person who ever died with kovid that was
not listed as a code of death that's
true that's true he did have the covid
George Floyd yeah if I say that do I am
I going to be sued no I mean but he did
hey by the way I'm fine with it
but but look if the guy in Michigan that
shot himself that had coveted can be
counted as a covet death yeah I think it
was in Michigan you don't think you
don't think a 12 gauge through the
forehead would actually be contributing
to well you know what that's the problem
it was a contributing factor he can
stare he can stare facts right in the
face and just ignore them must be do be
nice to go through life Bliss
Bliss Fair pre-existing condition it
didn't matter you think that it was you
think that it was the Mossberg at his
Temple and not the slight cough you
insensitive prick that's my fault guys I
have some growing to do oh by the way
before I move on here to Joy reading
everything she said is wrong uh this is
a wonderful sponsor of the show you've
heard me talk about X clear the nasal
spray uh spry gum you can get this at
most pharmacies or Amazon
a lot of people don't know about this I
actually think doctor I think it was it
Rhonda Patrick was on Joe Rogan talking
about chewing Xylitol gum yeah so
Xylitol actually
um there there's a Litany of benefits
that you can uh you can go read up I
think on the website uh regarding your
mouth and regarding sort of the what's
the equivalent to a microbiome in your
mouth the film of bacteria uh that's
basically what this does you can chew it
between brushings I have not had a
cavity in my adult life
really yeah I have one tiny small thing
because I didn't have my wisdom tooth
removed and it's back in my gum and they
said yeah you're probably gonna have to
have that removed because that's gonna
grow it's never grown I mean we know how
bad Dave's mouth is can can it clean his
mouth
is squeaky clean I've never had a cavity
really that's good got my wisdom teeth
out the day of the biggest blackout in
the history of uh Michigan it was when
it shut out part of Canada yeah Detroit
I remember that I was in Ohio well you
know like nowadays so when I was a kid I
used to try and be rebellious I'm not
going to brush my teeth you know my
parents said you have to uh but I just
realized I could have just said uh I'm
gonna take puberty blockers in it they
wouldn't be able to do anything I know
they would have been like yeah you don't
need to yeah you don't need to yeah
you'd be you right I identify as a
platypus yeah British yeah
I identify as common Street trash yes so
go to x clear.com and or you can just go
buy it in a drugstore Pharmacy I mean I
actually have like oral cancer right
diabetes Alzheimer's or a bunch of
benefits to it you can have covet in
your mouth just so you know go look it
up okay yeah let's get to Joy Reed
oh yeah I'm a [ __ ]
there it is
now I don't want to say that she uh lies
about everything she lies about some
things but she's at the very least wrong
about everything so yesterday she went
on a tirade uh and by the way when they
start attacking people that means those
are the people they're afraid of so you
see it with Kanye West and you see it of
course with Ron DeSantis and of course
you've seen it with Donald Trump
um she wanted a tie it against Ron
DeSantis and she tried to say that
Florida is the best example to use as a
modern Jim Crow State now first let me
preface this my bias uh here is if
that's a Jim Crow State then sign me up
but here she is making her stupid case
it's a warm in tonight with Florida
which I would argue even with Texas
existing has emerged as the modern state
in this country that comes the closest
to a modern day version of Jim crowd in
Texas
if there is a state that better
exemplifies the rot of Maga Republican
rule than the State of Florida that the
governor has named in very orwellian
fashion the free state of Florida I
honestly don't know where it is don't
know what it is I mean Florida has it
all a law Banning gay people from
declaring their existence at school
teachers can actually get fired for it a
law against anti-racist policies at work
like you have to let the racism be in
the workplace or else
book bands and requirements for
patriotic Christian education propaganda
in public schools and of course a
concerted effort to make it as hard as
possible for anyone who might vote for
the out of power party the Democrats
hashtag black people to vote or to have
representative districts Florida's Jim
Crow Redux Governor Ron DeSantis even
has his own office of election crimes
okay so there's so much there uh let's
break down some of the claims and lies
from Joy read slash Gary Oldman from The
Fifth Element and see what it is that we
who wore it better oh do you have to ask
my boy Gary
rocked it at first I was thinking she
looked like the Halle Berry in The
Flintstones but then I realized Halle
Berry was far too attractive too
complimentary yeah
[Laughter]
Halle Berry's Beauty blinded me to what
a crap hole that film was yeah you just
watched her the whole movie and how bad
an actress she is stop it don't choose
the lady the lady has an Oscar well
excuse me maybe you've not seen her
breasts and swordfish so does Randy
Newman or a monsters ball yeah or pretty
much every film yeah or I don't remember
anything else about those movies but I
do remember the breast I do remember the
breasts I have made my point I also
remember the breast and Catwoman even
though she didn't show them because when
I was watching the film I was just
picturing her breasts that's right that
was one that she was a quality actor the
whole time I was a get in the suit oh
remember Gothica yeah yeah yeah that too
was awful but her breasts it's not bad
yeah terrible film what do we do with
this terrible film I don't know call
Halle Berry I know we need breasts they
just walk up they're like hey Mrs Perry
uh you know we've been doing some some
reshoots here and uh this film is uh it
doesn't seem like it's very good do you
think you could uh show your breasts one
step ahead of you she's just right yeah
she's like I say no extra 200 Grand each
yes she's like these are insured it's
key tit Insurance oh boy
statement there every single statement
is factually incorrect and I don't know
how that happens by accident I've got to
believe that she is proactively lying at
this point but I do like the fact that
she fit in hashtag black people I know
that like yes doesn't let hashtag black
people vote I'm like that's a weird
that's like the the soccer mom trying to
be hip in the van like hey kids did you
have a good hashtag soccer practice yeah
you're like shut up mom because they're
spoiled they throw a shoe at her they
just jerk the wheel into oncoming
traffic
and just being strung behind the van
afterwards like just married cans the
point is she's insufferable so let's go
through all of it here's one claim that
she made of course that the teachers in
Florida uh who can't be gay and they'll
be fired for their existence let's just
let's just play the clip I mean Florida
has it all a law abandoning gay people
from declaring their existence at school
teachers can actually get fired no and
no so the don't say gay bill which is
maybe how you know it if you're a stupid
person uh it never actually mentions the
word gay here's the actual text of the
bill classroom instruction by school
Personnel or third parties on sexual
orientation or gender identity may not
occur in kindergarten through grade
three or in a manner that is not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students in accordance
with State Standards so to oppose that
you must you must be maintaining the
position and uh your position is that it
is appropriate for kindergarten through
the third grade to teach them about
sexual orientation and hypersexualized
issues that's the only way you can
actually oppose this bill doesn't say
doesn't say that you can't be a teacher
if you happen to be gay your students
just don't need to know who you're
plowing that day exactly it doesn't even
say that you can't tell your co-workers
about your spouse being gay as well
right so it doesn't say any of that
stuff it just says that a five-year-old
doesn't need to know that right yeah it
doesn't even know your first name either
that's true Mr or Mrs or I don't know
there's other things now so is it Z yeah
Z I don't know where you start with that
you don't give her an app you don't give
Z an apple you just give him like a nice
like oblong pair can you be like call me
call me Dave and sit on a chair like AC
Slater so they're like this guy's cool
as hell yeah yeah yeah that's the kind
of teacher I would be exactly and then
you can you have a side hustle selling
drugs yeah or like yeah like the
substitute yep with uh we all knew where
to get some nice speed balls here's
another claim that she makes right there
about Florida uh Banning anti-racist
laws I just listen to her a law against
anti-racist policies at work like you
have to let the racism be in the
workplace or else
incorrect here's the truth
the Santa signed the stop woke act hb7
so w-o-k-e you know it's an acronym uh
into law in April I believe 2022. uh
here's what the law actually does it
makes it illegal for employers including
schools by the way to require training
or promote ideas such as an individual's
moral character status as either
privileged or pressed based on race
color sex or national origin so
basically talking about the fact that
you are not allowed to teach people that
they are inherently discriminated
against because of insert whichever
identity politics here they wanted to
make it merit-based right or privileged
yep either way or educated by the way it
also makes it illegal this bill to
discriminate against any individual or
group to achieve what diversity Equity
or inclusivity I've talked about this in
the past do you believe in equality then
you can't believe in equity do you
believe an equal outcome then you can't
believe in equality it's either equality
of opportunity or Equity meaning insured
equal outcomes right which by its very
definition has to be racist we're going
to do a change my mind on this you know
there aren't a lot of women in the
military
I think it's now enlisted forces have
gone up to 13 uh but here's what's
fascinating about the military about
half
would be minorities Hispanic black
in enlisted Services because it really
is a meritocracy it's about can you can
you meet the requirements right that
that is one of the great ironies here
when you make something merit-based you
tend to actually see more diversity so
the bill just says you can't actually
teach people that there's inherent
racism without evidence and it's illegal
to discriminate against anyone based on
race class sexual orientation in order
to try and artificially ensure Equity it
is an anti-racist Bill Joy reads a
racist and she is exactly right she is
promoting racism but only if it's
directed at one group of people this
sounds exactly like what was happening
in slavery like you could be racist just
against black people in slavery right
that was the thing now it's like no no
no we've just replaced that with white
people you can discriminate against
white people to make sure that everybody
else has an opportunity let's go one
step further
white victim no no okay what about
Asians so here's an example a law like
this in Florida is very necessary so
they don't have the kinds of problems
that you have at Brown or at Harvard
where they were refusing to enroll
Asians and universities in order to
achieve diversity meaning Asians with
better scores meaning Asian students who
are better qualified they were being
rejected why to ensure Equity of outcome
in University so you don't even talk
about the white thing you can talk about
anyone who isn't the cause du jour and
by the way remember stop Asian hate
sorry Asians the Democrats have no use
for you anymore hey black Americans
maybe it was it going to midterms Trends
are more useful at that point and they
might silence black female voices namely
black women who compete in sports for
example the uh track athletes in
Connecticut it can't be consistent and
so it has to self-destruct but only only
if the information
can be delivered to you directly and
that's why they don't want the Alex
Jones out there that's why they don't
want this show that's why they don't
want people like Kanye or anyone even
expressing opinions you know what let's
not use them as examples how about uh
the sitting president of the United
States Donald Trump being removed from
all of social media that should tell you
where they line up if that isn't just
something that is terrifying to you that
a sitting president while the Ayatollah
still has a profile I know it's
repetitive this is remedial at this
point but it's a big deal
well it should be repetitive when
nothing's changed I know I mean it's
been three years of nonsense well people
are not just now accepting of that
they're promoting that well and here's a
good example too they will say oh yeah
your [ __ ] this is a constant argument
right you [ __ ] about cancel culture
while you're selling books yeah Kanye is
really hurting for money well often they
they succeed in spite of that let me
give you an example Carrie Lake very
likely to be the next governor of
Arizona okay Kerry Lake was on this show
and she was questioning some issues
regarding a primary she won
now she just wanted to win right if she
was just looking to achieve political
political power
she would have kept her mouth shut it
was something she won and she said I
want to know exactly how I want I want
to know by how many votes and I want to
make sure that my constituents the
voters can trust this election that was
removed here from YouTube so if Kerry
lake is governor of Arizona it's in
spite of the fact that millions of plays
were stripped probably tens of millions
if you add up all of the other platforms
all the other pieces of content that
were removed so she's not doing well
because she's a white woman she's doing
well in spite of the fact that you are
trying to silence her don't just look at
the end result that's the problem with
identity politics you say oh you must be
so impressed you're a white man you're
doing okay do you think it's because
he's a white man do you think Kanye is
doing all right because he's a man by
the way I love how we've eliminated
black at that point you're completely
allowed to destroy a black American if
they just happen to be conservative Like
Larry Elder where you can throw bananas
at him while wearing a gorilla mask I
just still my brain partially explodes
when I say that out loud it happened
it's on camera nothing oh yeah that was
a hate crime that was really insane yeah
I don't even believe it
that's getting pretty close well he's
the black face of white supremacy
Stephen we now have that
you can hit the like button you know I'm
pretty pretty sure it's there you can
hit the like button helps with the
algorithm because you know hey that
stuff gets removed go and watch the
Kelly Lake episode that's been removed
here from YouTube you can watch that mug
Club here's another claim that Joy reads
slash Gary Oldman from uh Fifth Element
made
but they're a book band right book bands
and requirements to ban more books in
Florida and that they require you
actually instead uh uh use patriotic
Christian education propaganda in public
schools hear her say it book bands and
requirements for patriotic Christian
education propaganda in public schools
okay yeah again these are short phrases
because she went through a whole
paragraph it was like a cipher of
[ __ ]
well she narrowed it down for us it made
the clips easier to get together so that
is incorrect here's the truth
the books in question that are not
allowed in the education curriculum in
Florida all feature
incredibly sexually explicit content uh
by the way things like you know
masturbating until climax things like
underage gay sex things like sexual
assault again which let's call us old
novels yes exactly it yeah it where
she's like oh my gosh I think your
powers are fading you must all quick the
only answer is to run a train on me well
how do you know that call it a hunch
turns out there was no clown people
don't realize that if you've only seen
the film here are the top five books
that by the way are banned uh in Florida
and by Band they mean not
age-appropriate to teach to Children
genderqueer a memoir uh all boys aren't
blue Lawn Boy out of Darkness The Bluest
Eye I thought it would be the brownest
eye you can see all of these at
ladderwithcreditor.com for the
references uh all have an incredibly
sexually explicit
we've also banned pool boy yes yes the
bluest ball is also on that list
and here's the thing this is not Banning
books from the Public Square it's saying
well this probably shouldn't be taught
to kids let's contrast that with
examples of books that the left has
actively tried to ban
Like To Kill a Mockingbird
they wanted by the way if the
anti-racist book If the book that says
hey hold on a second we need to
acknowledge that we have these Prejudice
and it's wrong and that just because a
man is black does not mean that he
forfeits his rights what are you saying
he needed a white lawyer probably back
then yeah it helps wasn't Harper Lee a
woman
I was still thinking about Emmett Till
what sorry wasn't Harper Lee a woman who
wrote A To Kill a Mockingbird yeah yeah
like had to make her name sound like a
man's just to get it published well then
you have Boo Radley and I just the point
is there was an anti-racist book and now
they're saying anti-racist books are
racist yeah what was anti-racist written
by a woman who probably couldn't have
had it published if she didn't have a
male sounding name at the time so they
want to get rid of To Kill a Mockingbird
uh The Adventures of Huckleberry Finn
hey here's the thing you may not like
that the n-word is said in that book did
you notice that a friendship grows
between a white kid and a black kid
despite racial discrimination at that
point in time not to mention Dr Seuss
books because they're racist and
whatever it is insert here so we have on
one side not the Banning of books but
saying you shouldn't teach this to
Children Well I don't want my son
reading a book where a guy talks about
masturbating in a broom closet all right
that one's Fair versus you guys saying
To Kill a Mockingbird isn't anti-racist
enough and even though it's a huge part
of American history and it's a
fantastically written piece of of
fiction uh we're gonna ban that just
where do do you line up
one is actual censorship and one is
about age I don't have a PR it's the
difference between a rating system with
films
versus just banning all films
it's the difference between saying like
a Christian Evangelical said well we
just don't think South Park should be on
you know early because it's not
age-appropriate which by the way uh
Stone and Parker said yeah we agree
versus Banning episodes because it
features Muhammad which Comedy Central
did with South Park very very different
a rating system versus all-out
censorship here's another bit of Truth
uh when she says you know they want to
push Christian propaganda instead
Florida's Civics literacy
uh Excellence initiative is what it's
called it's not Christian propaganda
just to be clear it's an initiative that
focuses on including at least some
patriotic form of education meaning that
you can't only espouse revisionist
history for example like at Berkeley if
you go and watch that video where they
taught their students that we created
slavery that we kidnapped people from
the old world and turned them into
slaves in the new world ignoring the
fact that 90 something percent on the
low end 90 on the likely end 98 were
sold into slavery by Western North
African slave traders to begin with you
just have to teach both sides of it
because if you actually learn human
history you will understand that you
know what United States flawed pretty
decent place so the initiative focuses
on that kind of education here's a quote
resources will highlight patriotism
based on the personal stories of diverse
individuals who demonstrate Civic minded
qualities including first-person
accounts of victims of other nations
governing philosophies who can compare
with those philosophies of the United
States hmm I think that's probably the
one that they hate the most because they
it's like hey socialism well we're going
to teach you about all of the Socialist
places in the world in existence over
time and show you how they suck compared
to the United States yeah we don't
really want that yeah well these people
who by the way you have like Tom Morello
out there who has the that's why we have
the Che Guevara shirts The Rage Against
the Machine you do realize Che Guevara
uh killed gays and also hated blacks
right have you read shank event we've
done a whole segment on that he hated
blacks and he actually enjoyed watching
the Firing Squad at work
didn't you want to have a wall removed
yeah you want to have a wall removed
from his office so he could actually
watch them at work he was like hitter
Hitler only less effective in his
attempted genocide
poof
now when people say are you saying it no
I'm not saying it's a good thing I'm
saying Hitler was effective at
implementing his horrible agenda Che
Guevara had a horrible racist agenda
that he was not effective at
implementing thank God as far as how it
impacted the rest of the world but you
go and wear your shirt so when you see
the chick of air shirt think Hitler
without the charm to some people
so patriotism is propaganda now to
Joyride yes correct anything that paints
the United States as being a a Bastion
for freedom and democracy is just
against What She Likes right well people
are triggered by the American flag now I
mean that's not surprising I mean
there's plenty of people in this country
that aren't have no patriotism and I'm
not saying you should be rah-rah all the
time and you shouldn't question your
government but being anti your own
country is very bizarre to me she's
describing hell she is literally
describing what she's making up a place
that doesn't exist yeah where my son in
three years could come home with one of
those books as a five-year-old teaching
him how to masturbate or gay anal sex or
I didn't even realize sexual assault
included in this book if this was all
about straight sex if this was all about
teaching kids just say sex
well I did did said gay sex yeah but I'm
just saying it's redundant to say
straight sex well no I'm saying like if
this is thank you I've said gay anal sex
and then straight sex this is about sex
regular and a woman yeah having sex I
would still not want the book to be
there for my five-year-old son no you
don't want to read 50 Shades of Gray to
yourself yeah no I don't want to read 50
Shades of Gray and I don't want my son
to think that he grows up in a hellhole
and I don't want my son to think that
he's an oppressor that needs to get down
on his knees and kiss people's feet that
he has done nothing wrong to him would
probably befriend on the playground and
play ball with yep that's what I want my
son not to have to do and joy reads
describing all of that well I think it's
a double standard because who can forget
when our substitute teacher rolled in
the VHS television and showed us show
Girls oh I remember those days
she was just trying to make a living
Stephen no that's a good point you know
what you're going to create more racism
than ever Joy Reid wants a more racist
America than ever in its history if you
teach young white kids that they're evil
for something over which they have no
control and by the way have you ever
looked at any social experiment
conducted with children where you've
given one
versus the other authority they
immediately wield it and they're
immediately abusive what do you think is
going to happen if you say hold on a
second this is the hierarchy you're
black therefore you've been oppressed so
you're going to get special privileges
you're white so you need to be brow
beaten and you need to feel guilty what
kind of dynamic do you think is going to
set up and how do you think that young
white boy is going to grow up who do you
think he will grow up to be
you think think there might be some
resentment for the same reason
rightfully so that young black boys who
grew up pre-civil rights there who grew
up in actual Jim Crow South guess what
had every reason to be resentful
we see this in all these films like oh
you just end up perpetuating a cycle of
violence as they do it in front of your
eyes based on a lie none of that upsets
me as much as the brownest eye where the
boy masturbates furiously at his desk
chair I don't think my child should be
reading that nope it is not even I have
no idea I just don't why would you read
it I I guess I don't understand like
this is for elementary levels well I
mean I don't know exactly what level but
it's in the library yeah right so at
schools right so Library it's not
there's another R in there Dave we are
going to read you another wonderful
American classic today this is from the
magazine section it is known as fangoria
yes enjoy Hustler yes hey this is called
House Forum yes here's a letter we've
replaced Huckleberry Finn with the
adventures of jugs with a z Yes dear
Penthouse I was straight from the
convenience store with the thing
covering the front we'll remove that wow
look at this boys and girls yes and I
might Direct your attention for more
resources to buttpimples.com
what do you mean they're not naked in
Playboy anymore oh that's why I went out
of business yes stories let's go on to I
think this is the final claim from Joy
Reid don't know how she gets it all
wrong that uh of course and this is the
coup de gras that uh a conservatives uh
Florida they want to make it to illegal
for blacks to vote or something then of
course a concerted effort to make it as
hard as possible for anyone who might
vote for the out of power party the
Democrats hashtag black people to vote
or to have representative districts look
I just I'm not going to read the quote
because you know where this is going you
can go check out the website for all the
references here's the truth uh Senate
Bill 90 it just it just strengthens
voter ID laws you just you just need
some identification so that we know who
you are when you're voting and by the
way I dare you a huge portion majority
of Americans support requiring voter ID
including about 70 of black Americans
and uh when you take all minorities
together it's 82 so I guess were they
racist
how was how is identification racist oh
because black people can't afford it
it's free well black people don't have a
car there's a bus well some black people
don't know how to use the bus well they
can walk well they're more likely to
have diabetes do you hear how racist
your [ __ ] is and by the way are there
not poor white people poor Asians poor
Hispanics that might have the same
challenges and you're like well no it's
just aimed at black people because we're
poorer right and we're less capable
we've been told that our entire lives so
it must be true right the Democratic
party thinks so little of you I can't
imagine being an adult and being able to
rest my head on my pillow at night and
feel good about myself if I believed
what the what the joy reads of the world
were telling me boy talk about a way to
shatter any hope and you want to do that
with children so what does she say oh
you're going to be fired if you're gay
okay that's not true it's not even
remotely true uh they want you to not be
able to vote okay that's not true they
want Christian propaganda that's not
true they want to ban books no they just
want age-appropriate books you want to
ban books because you don't think that
they meet your woke quota enough every
single thing that she said in the span
of about what 40 seconds what do we
wreck up six lies
hey why do you mistrust your
institutions
by the way we're going to go here to a
mug club or we can talk about these
things without worrying about getting in
trouble share the show sharing is caring
we appreciate it because it helps us
with the algorithm on YouTube if you
search this show and its name you won't
find it uh YouTube must go faster
must go faster
okay must go faster
all right thank you
Dave's going to be in Kansas City you
too piss off
oh
foreign
[Music]